today
uh clearly i am a noble gas
um and so
thanks to is actually the ta's idea so
and i was like of course that sounds
awesome so
um i hope you guys have a fantastic
halloween
obviously what you want to do is any
kind of trick-or-treating or
partying you know the drill you bring
your periodic table because you never
know
and and that's what happened you know so
on sunday
right before the exam i got this and um
okay so so this is uh charles and
raymond and they're saying
we wanted to celebrate the sox victory
in boston
but because the midterm was the next day
we brought along our periodic table to
study
there were so many people moving around
it felt like we were in a sea
of electrons and of course the only
thing that could have improved on that
was actually like a little dance video
but that'll probably come i'm sure
they're on that next um but see they
brought it
not just to study for the exam because
they didn't know if it was going to be
important or not
at the rally you never know right so
so make sure you have your periodic
table with you um
now uh okay oh
yeah they mentioned the exam so speak
speaking of the exam um here are the
results
and um you can see that there's a pretty
wide distribution
um you can also see the average is a 77
and just to remind you that's that's
about here
just to remind you these uh these uh
marks 85
that's the a range this is the b range
right so the average was in the solid b
range territory um
and and then and so it goes um
the standard deviation was 12.
now i could tell
you know exam one i think a lot of the
topics of exam one
many of you had already seen and i think
in this exam
some of you had not seen some of these
topics especially like the crystal
crystallography but also even the
molecular orbitals the band structure
and and i could tell that you know so
some people were a little bit
uh maybe uh you know you had to work a
little harder maybe a little
bit stressed and i could sense uh some
of that
uh but you know when i when i get
stressed what i do
is i need to kind of de-stress somehow
and sometimes you know some people
listen to music
some of the other things i always like
comedy
as a way of of relaxing and so what i do
is i'll google like for articles about
about harvard um and i found
and so i found this one
this is actually an article in the
crimson and you know and so
some a few years ago and uh the most
common grade at harvard is actually an a
an a a solid a the most common grade
um um and i like there's a okay
suspicion that the college employs a
softer grading standard than many of its
peer
institutions you think if everyone i
mean
if everyone's getting an a you think i i
mean but the thing is
uh so what i wanted to point out is like
there's a difference
right and it's not just about uh okay
your privilege therefore you deserve an
a
um whereas we know that that actually
takes
work that's not the point i want to make
the point i want to make is that we know
also what to do when we miss things
we know what to do when we don't get
things right right
that's when you do the work you know so
wherever you are
on this curve go back and figure out
what didn't work
what did you miss figure that out
because that's where you learn
right i mean there's a thomas edison who
said i never failed
i just did 10 000 experiments that
didn't work
right that you know you got to get
through that you got to know that it
takes hard work and that's the thing
that we know here
that's the difference so please make
sure you do that with exam two
we are all here to help you continue
learning
on the noble gas anyway
okay and speaking of continuing to learn
um right where were we x-rays
so the last time now um
uh on friday we had sort of you know
some other things going on but i also
was trying to teach you guys about
x-rays
and because in type and
and what we did is we learned how
they're generated right remember that
the renkin
experiments right um and so i want to
pick up here with the kinds of x-rays
that we have
there are two kinds of x-rays right um
and and we learned about those on on
friday and i want to just remind you
about those
and i also want to um show you a video
uh to kind of recapture what they are
and the the the first kind of x-ray
remember we plotted this as intensity
and i'm not going to
i'm not going to draw the cathode ray
tube again and the experiment that
renkin did and all that
but but i'm going to just jump to the
two kinds of x-rays that you get
right and so if you plot the
the wavelength of the x-ray versus the
intensity of the x-ray
right then one kind is the
bremsstrahlung
which comes from that that electron
getting slowed down
and and if it slows down it emits
radiation
in a continuous spectrum right and so
so you might get you know remember we
we sort of drew these these
yeah okay and and this might be you know
this would be like the incident
electron energy right incident
let's say incident um
energy of the electron okay maybe like
that's uh
okay i don't know like 10 kav 10
kv and then up here the incident energy
of the electron was
you know something like maybe 30 kev
right and so
you see that it it as you as you hit
that anode that remember what rinkin did
he took a cathode ray tube and he
upped the voltage so he really cranked
up the voltage so those electrons coming
off the cathode
are going really fast right and then
what he did is he put a piece of metal
in their way
and and what happened is those really
high energy electrons
they see those metal atoms and sometimes
they get inside the electron cloud and
they turn
and that's when they give off this
continuous radiation
right but but but we also know that
there's a limit here
we right remember that we talked about
that and that this limit
limit is set by
this maximum
this it's just the the maximum that you
could
the maximum amount of energy that you
could get out of a photon being emitted
this way
would be equal to the incoming electron
the incoming electron
transferred all of its energy to the
photon so that's why there's a maximum
and and it's also why it increases
remember
right shorter wavelength higher energy
right so it increases
as you increase the energy of the
incident electron
okay that is brem strolling let's watch
a video because i
this is actually a very nicely done uh
video that captures it with animation
so okay so here's your crt now okay here
they come
those are those electrons in there
voltage is high
so they're coming out look at them
coming out really fast right
lots of kinetic energy okay
and then there they go and they put and
this is what rincon did he put a little
piece of metal in there so now those
electrons are hitting the metal
okay so those are the two things that
you differently remember the room lit up
even when all the lights were off okay
there they are
nice good electrons oh and here they go
and there's the metal atom
okay and oh look at that now what are
these
those are x-rays coming off those are
the electrons hitting the metal and
here's the metal atom
and as the electron comes in remember it
sees the charge
of the nucleus and it gets deflected
and that deflection loses energy and
that loss of energy goes into a photon
now because
these electrons have such high energy to
start with
because they have such high energy to
start with um
you know the energies of the photons are
very high
and they're x-rays right they're x-rays
um and so okay and so here's the
wavelength and you can see that
uh well it's sort of a little hard to
see in this blue range but see higher
energy
shorter wavelength lower energy longer
wavelength very nice okay so that's the
animation of brem stalling
now okay good now the thing is what we
also learned
is that there's another type of x-ray
there's another type of x-ray
and and in fact if you crank this up
high enough
you get that you can get that other type
so now we go higher oh
we didn't see it here it just looks like
that and that and that and then
all of a sudden we go up to 40 kev
and we see this
why right what happened here and what
happened here is a totally different
mechanism for generating x-rays right
and that was the second type that we
talked about on friday those peaks
are called characteristic and and the
reason is
that remember we have these
levels which now that we are talking
about x-rays
we give them letters k l m
n but it's just the quantum numbers n
equals 1
n equals 2 right okay
n equals 3 n equals 4.
and what we said is that the way
characteristic x-rays
are labeled is that if an electron is
excited from this gazentite
from this lower level right if an
electron
is is knocked out of here then there's a
place for an electron from here to go
down
maybe the electron is excited maybe the
electron is kicked out
and then something here can come down
and when that happens
just like just like
in the bohr model you get
radiation right but now unlike hydrogen
13.6 electrons these are kev of energy
these are very high energies why because
it's the 1s electron
and we know that once you get down to
those metals right
wait those 1s electrons you go down
further down the periodic table those 1s
electrons
are seriously tightly bound yeah
and and those levels have a have a
difference
down there that is pretty high in energy
it's x-ray high in energy
that's the point so now when that
cascade happens we call that a k
alpha and if it were to have come from
here
it would be called a k beta right
and and those are transitions that
unlike
this continuous energy those transitions
only happen at very specific energies
delta
delta energies right the change in
energy from
l to k or or for k beta would be going
from
m to k you say it's k
alpha k beta you use the k because
that's the final place the electron
goes when it it decays down okay
so if you had to if i just showed you
these
and say well that would be like k alpha
and that would be like k beta because
you know
that k beta is going to be a higher
energy photon right because it came up
from a higher level
okay well you would also have on here
some other
peaks right you would have the l peaks
right
so you'd have like l
alpha l beta
right see so you see so so as you crank
the energy up
right then you can knock out those core
electrons and these cascades happen
and you get these discrete peaks notice
they will only come when you have enough
elect enough energy in that incident
electron
to knock this electron out from the core
so that's why they don't appear until
you get to a certain
incident electron energy right they
don't appear until you get to that
certain energy right and so we have a
video
on that which also i will narrate
but is this
it there we go okay so there it is
it's a metal atom i don't know which one
um
and what you're okay there's the
incident electron you fired it and look
at that
it knocked out a core 1s electron
because it had enough energy
very high energy that's what rinkan did
crank up the voltage
higher kb and there it is a cascade down
and an x-ray comes out
you see that okay so so that
uh very uh is that all oh yeah and then
it's gonna draw
because of those you get these
characteristic peaks now we call them
characteristic
because now you can see why so unlike
the continuous radiation
right these peaks depend on the atom
because they depend on the energy levels
of the atom
right and so that's why like if you look
this up you say well okay let's look at
the k
alpha radiation let's look at the
k-alpha peaks
right that come out of of different
atoms they're going to be different
okay like so so you have so you have
very sharp
lines of of x-rays at
very specific energies for copper it's 8
kv for
for molybdenum it's 17.5 right silver
tungsten
it changes and you can see that it goes
up right
as you as that 1s electron is lower and
lower in energy because i'm adding all
these protons
so it all makes sense from the concepts
we've learned
oh but see now now that's really useful
that is really useful because now i've
got a way
to have a source of x-rays that is super
well defined it's super clear it's
always this ah that's so cool
it as long as i have the same metal it's
always the same
right i can increase or decrease well i
can't
go below the threshold but i can go
above it and that peak is
characteristic of the metal
so it doesn't change that's really
useful
because i've got now a flashlight i've
got an x-ray flashlight
where the energy that i'm sending out is
always exactly what i know it to be
i can predict what it is and it always
will be that depending
on which metal i put in there right so
so that's a useful
that's a useful thing why is that useful
well that gets to the the topic that is
the topic of today
and a friday which is what are we doing
with these x-rays well first we're
generating them so that's what we've
talked about so far
right but now because in tight we're
going to actually use them
to determine the crystal that we have
we're going to actually use them we're
going to use that flashlight
okay and and so you know so you can see
why this would be useful because
here is the this is the range we've
showed this before
right of x-rays so they they have these
energies of kev
and they have wavelengths right around a
few angstroms
that's a little less than an angstrom
maybe two angstroms right see where
those wavelengths are
well those are atomic spacings
those are like distances between layers
right and so if we could shine these on
a crystal
and and somehow figure out what it is
with that
light oh there's a way we can do that
it's called diffraction
because what happens is and and we know
this from
from many fields this is you can think
about this just as a water wave
any wave okay if the wavelength
is similar in size
to the features then you get
constructive and destructive
interference
as a result of the interaction between
the wave and the features
so that's called diffraction right and
you can see it here with this very
simple
uh picture of say a water this could be
like a water wave a sound wave
you know and there it is and it's it's
interfering
uh both constructively and destructively
along these lines
right you can do this test yourself
you could take um i highly recommend
this take a laser pointer
and uh now if i is there now if i just
had a piece of metal
i don't have a piece of metal but if i
did
then i would shine it on it and what
you'd see is that the dot would just
reflect off the piece of metal
okay so i just would get the dot back
right
but now i've got this thing here this we
many of you may not know what this
is um this is called a cd
okay and oh but it turns out that a cd
has
it has features and it's got trenches
that are like
you know a little less than a micron
apart 800 nanometers
and this is 500 nanometer light so you
would expect there to be diffraction
you would expect there to be
constructive and destructive
interference and when i
bounce it off of this look at that there
it is
this never gets old i'm not getting
i'm not getting just one reflection
here i'm getting a whole scatter of them
that have
constructively interfered because of the
feature sizes being
the same as the as the wavelength
okay but now i want to do that with
x-rays and i want to do it
onto onto crystals so how do we do that
okay so let's think about that and we're
going to think about it in terms of what
the bragg father-son pair
who won the nobel prize and are on a
stamp that's what you get uh
when you win a nobel prize i guess um
and um
and what they did is they figured out
how to do this okay
so let's let's go through that just so
we understand it conceptually
um okay so
if i have i'm going to say that i have a
set
of atoms now right now i'm not going to
worry about
what they are um
but i'm just going to say that there's
some plane of atoms here
and there's another plane of atoms
beneath that
okay so there's another one and
so on and so on and now these
these would be miller planes right these
would be miller planes in the crystal
and let's just assume they're very very
simple this plane in that plane
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to have some x-rays i'm going to
have some light
shining on this and it's going to be
incident
and it's going to be reflected but see
i'm going to have another wave here
okay let's see if i can get through this
drawing
sort of almost kind of um
now here's the deal okay
these are waves right these are waves so
if i had if if i want to draw this as a
wave
i might draw it like that and if these
are if these waves
are constructively interfering
let's just complete that then this wave
would look
like that right if they're the same if
they're in phase then that's what they
would look like
now this one's getting reflected off the
surface right so i'm going to do that
reflection here
okay and if i want it to come back
off of the surface and i want and this
one
got through the first layer this didn't
get reflected it's going down
and if i want it to come back up then
this one must also look like that
to be in phase right they must be in
phases as they come out
or else they're not going to interfere
constructively you see that
so those are my x-rays right they're
waves they're just waves
right oh but this is the this is the
whole secret
right because you know if if this is
if this angle here is theta
then what that means is that this angle
is theta
okay well yeah and if that's true
then this distance is d
sine theta where this is d
that's just some some simple geometry
okay so so what you know then is
okay now now we're getting somewhere
right now we're getting somewhere
because you know
if i had a wave this is one wavelength
right
and so so if i had a wave um
come in like this and and one of them is
going to get reflected off of this lower
surface
and the other one got reflected off this
but i don't want them to interfere in
any way but constructively
that's what that's what bragg said
bragging brag
that's what they said then the only way
for that to happen
is if this distance plus that distance
so
d sine theta plus d sine theta is equal
to
some multiple of the wavelength it has
to be
right and so what you get is
well that's what they have there n
lambda some multiple of the wavelength
equals 2d
sine theta where theta is
the incident angle of that x-ray
okay so this is incident just to be
clear
incident x-ray
and these are reflected
reflected x-rays
okay now to keep it simple in this class
we're just going to
say n equals 1. n equals 1
for 3091 just to keep things
simple because we're really just i want
to grasp the basic concepts here
all right we're not using x-rays to get
the the structure of dna but we're going
to use x-rays to figure out cubic
crystal structures we're going to show
how that works
now so this
must be true for so this is in
parentheses
four construction interference
constructive
interference those dots that you saw
interface interface no
interference interference
right for this is true
for constructive interference of course
you could write any equation you want
but if you want them to be
constructively
interfering when they come out that has
to be true and that's what the bragg
said but see that we're not there yet
right because now we got to do
experiments
okay so we got to do experiments so how
so what does this mean well
okay i'm going to
i'm going to take x-rays of some lambda
okay and i'm going to shine them on a
sample
right okay and i'm going to measure so
what i'm going to do
oh i think i have a picture i'm going to
measure there it is
this is what an x-ray diffraction
experiment looks like
okay so i've got some sample and i shine
x-rays i've got a source of x-rays we
now know
how to make that source right and we'll
just filter out
one of these lines right okay so i've
got that source and i can change
the angle and then i've got a detector
and and i can measure did i get
interference or not it's just like the
dots
right so so now we know that if i if i
do that
and and i and i say i i scan
the um you know i scan the end okay so
i've got intensity
and now i'm plotting it with angle
so so now i'm moving this intensity
i'm moving the angle around and i'm
changing it bam i get interference and i
see a spot
in my detector so literally it would
look like this
right you would get some angle where
there's interference and the detector
will say ding ding ding ding ding i see
a lot of
x-rays coming off when i didn't and now
you change the angle by a few degrees
and i don't see anything
right because it's all destructive from
these crystal planes
okay okay so it seems like then if i
just vary theta
um am i there yet the problem is
that i might not know d i might not know
d
ah ha but we do know d
we do know d because we learned about d
for cubic crystals we know d
because because for cubic systems we
know
that d of h k l right
of any plane the distance between those
planes is equal to
a over the square root of h squared
plus k squared plus l squared and that's
something that
we learned this is distance
between miller planes
miller planes because then tight in
a cubic crystal
oh i'm saving time i wrote excel
i saved a lot of time which i just
wasted by being so proud of it
okay so
i know d well okay so what does that
mean well
let's take a look because now i'm going
to go back
i'm going to go back to my equation
and i'm going to say okay lambda equals
2d and i'm saying n equals one okay and
i'm going to be very specific this is
now
a d that comes from the spacing between
planes that are specified by the miller
indices
right times the sine of theta
right and i'm putting h k l on the theta
as well and you'll see why
because here's the thing now
i've got constants now i've got
constants because look
this is fixed
by the source by the source so this is a
constant
you know if if i have copper then it's
1.54 angstroms
right this is a constant this is fixed
by the crystal
that's also a constant fixed
by the crystal
because that's also a constant because
it's the lattice constant right we're
not changing that
so for a given set of planes that these
that these waves are bouncing off of and
and maybe maybe constructively
interfering with
right that depending on the theta
then then these are constants right
okay so so if i regroup them so i'm
going to regroup them
right and so i'm going to say that
let's see d so i'm going to substitute
in that expression up there down here
okay and i'm going to use a copper
source right so i'm going to say well
let me let me go through this one step
at a time so d
equals 1.54
over
let's see 2 sine
theta h k l now what have i done here
this is for a copper source so i'm i'm
now adding in
i'm fixing in the constant okay fixing
in the constant
okay so that's the brad condition but i
also know
that d is equal to
it's also equal to ah i don't want to
write it again
it's also equal to that okay
good okay so let's put that together
we'll do a little division
and what we get is 1.54 angstroms
over 2 a squared
the whole thing's squared i'm squaring
it i don't want the square root
equals sine squared theta
h k l over h
squared plus k squared plus l squared
four let's be very specific for
constructive interference
okay constructive
interference
and a copper source so now i'm getting
specific because this is how experiments
with x-ray diffraction are done right
so but now the last time i checked right
if you got something equal to a constant
then that something also is a constant
right and and this
is a constant yeah and and so so
what i need to do now is figure out
right i'm going to measure
these thetas where i get a signal
remember i'm going to i'm going to now
change
theta so that i see where do i get
signals
right now those thetas
divided by the plane that that that by
the hkl
that they are bouncing off of must be a
constant
they must not change that is at the
heart
of x-ray diffraction that is at the
heart of it
right all right so we're going to do
that
with a specific example today and friday
but before we do that
there's another thing that we can
observe there's another thing that we
can observe oh this is what it would
look like
so here it is right so so now i i've
changed now
why do we do two theta it's kind of
historical you plot
x-ray diffraction uh spectra so this is
an
xrd right x-ray diffraction spectrum
this is the intensity of the peaks
right and these are the peaks this is
like this is a beautiful thing i'm
seeing a crystal here
i'm seeing a crystal and by friday you
will be seeing a crystal
that those aren't just peaks those are
planes in a crystal
those are planes in a crystal which
tells me not only
that that i have these planes but it
tells me what crystal i have
but that's not how we start the way we
start is we do these measurements and we
just read off angles
so we got to get from there to there to
crystal structure so what i want to
determine
is the crystal structure and the lattice
constant that's my goal
what i have is a spectrum that looks
like this where all i've done here is
put these specific
angles here and you have to be given
okay so it's it this is the aluminum xrd
spectrum
so it's it's if you shine x-rays on
aluminum
this is what you get if you know also
that those x-rays are
from copper which means that lambda is
fixed
right so this would be like the in you
know the the information you'd get
to to start you'd be given this spectrum
you you're given these peaks
and you'll be given this information
here it's a copper target
and from that we can determine the
crystal structure in the lattice now
um now there's there's something
oh why do we write why do we do two
theta well it's historical
it could have been theta to make all
those dividing by twos
go away but instead you can see that as
i as i rotate this
right this changes by theta this the
detector changes by two theta
so that's why it's x-ray spectra are
given in two theta
there's no other real good reason for it
um
even though in the bragg condition it's
not two theta it's theta
right this comes from geometry okay of
the planes
and this just comes from historical
setups and then how you move the the
detector
okay so what's measured and plotted is
the two theta
okay now but before we go before we do
this transformation where we take an
x-ray spectrum
like this and and we and we get the
information we want
there's one more thing and that is
not all reflections are allowed not all
reflections are allowed
and and so and so let's talk about that
and then we'll come back to this
spectrum right
now you can you can kind of understand
this
by looking at just a simple uh kind of
comparison here
okay simple comparison all right if i
take so these are the hkls remember
that's the hkl for a miller plane
uh this is h squared plus k squared plus
l squared why do we put that
because we know we're going to need it
right there it is right there
so we know we're going to need it okay
but if you look at the simple cubic
that's simple cubic
right any combination of hkl is okay
there is no combination that would that
would give you
interference along that along those
planes stacking
let me say well i don't okay yeah what
are you talking about
why are you even bringing this up well
when you see the other two crystal
structures you'll see what i mean
so now we have the case of bcc right
when you see this you see bcc
and fcc and what i'm showing you here
isn't the 100 plane
it's the 20 plane right so this is the
family remember the family
of two old planes there they are there
they are
right oh but now
now you see that what happens
and i have a picture here to show you
but i'll tell you first what happens is
the light comes in so there's those
squiggly x-rays
right it comes in and and there's the
okay d
which depends on the lattice constant
right is related to the last
but look now there's another plane in
between
there's another plane in between and in
fact with the 200 planes
that plane in between exactly cancels
out the constructive interference here
it is
right so there's there's what i would
have had
right there's the the if you want to
think about this as the 100
100 right there's the 2os okay but
notice when i go from 100 to 20s i add
this
plane in here and and because that plane
has
atoms in it because that plane has atoms
in it it acts
like a mirror and it can also reflect
right it can also reflect
and so and so what happens is i would
have had this nice there it is there's a
picture i drew there's that
that first x-ray bouncing off there's
the second one bouncing off and those
are nicely in phase
so i would see that if that's the angle
that gave that to me i'd see that in the
detector
but now for bcc or fcc i've got
something in the middle
and that something in the middle is
exactly canceling out
you see that so now it cancels that out
in fact that's
that's called forbidden you won't see a
signal
it's right and so and so this is called
these are called selection rules right
these are called selection rules and
for simple cubic you can see there's
nothing inside
right so so there's nothing in this unit
cell
that could do this so everything's
allowed whether there's a plane in there
or not
it doesn't matter the selection rule is
whether it's ever allowed
whether it's ever allowed and for simple
cubic everything's fine
because nothing would cancel out but in
here
you see in this 2-0 case you can see
very clearly
from that picture how it cancels out but
there's many other kinds of
kinds of angles or or planes that might
also do that
right and so i'm going to just give you
what the selection rules are we won't go
through and derive them all
but let's see they are actually
quite simple and so i'm going to write
them down
right so for if we look at allowed
allowed reflections
and then we look at
forbidden
reflections so this is what the
selection rules
tell us okay so if it's if it's simple
cubic
then it's any h
k and l and there's no
forbidden reflections but if we go
through bcc and fcc
then what we find is that for bcc the
selection rule is that h
plus k plus l equals even
if that is even and we won't derive
these
but it comes from the same very simple
picture i just showed you
if something is in there that can cancel
out the constructive interference
it's going to be forbidden otherwise
it can constructively interfere and
that's what this tells us h
for bcc it turns out to be h plus k plus
l and so here
what's forbidden for bcc is h plus k
plus l
is odd and for fcc
it's h k l
all odd
or all even or all even
and the forbidden fcc
is h k l
mixed odd even
these are the selection rules
okay all right so if i were to give you
uh you know if i were to just to give
you the the planes that you see
then right away from an x-ray spectrum
you could just use these these selection
rules right away to know something
right to know something about it um and
if you work this out and you look at
okay so we have simple cubic
i mean there's this so okay so h squared
plus k squared plus they have one
100 bcc fcc you're not going to see it
that doesn't mean that there's no 100
plane in those crystals
it just means that if you shine x-rays
on it you will not see it
right you will not see it okay so uh the
1-1-0 though
now here okay so we so we see our oh by
the way
mixed even odd right and it adds to odd
that's why neither one of these works
here we go adds to even
bcc okay but it's still mixed even on
won't be fcc right three
right it's not mixed so it can it can be
a
allowable allowable reflection for fcc
but not for bcc because if you um
add them up it's odd and so forth and so
forth and look at seven doesn't exist
because you can't do
no matter how hard you try you can't get
seven
that's okay and there's eight and nine
and so forth right so nine also
yeah so so right so here it's allowed
but it's not allowed
in either of these because you can't get
um
you can't get the e you know you can't
get either of these to be satisfied
okay this is what selection rules give
us
and um and it comes again
from simple uh uh oh okay well that
that's another thing i said simple
i have to tell you something because the
brag condition
it relies on an assumption
that's mostly true but you know the the
bragg condition
requires
that the reflection is independent
some of you may be thinking did i did i
draw that onto the atom
or did i draw it in between the atoms
where did that thing ruffle doesn't have
to reflect off man
we're not going there with the brag
condition it's independent
independent okay of
the atom positions in a plane
and the second thing which is what i've
been sort of alluding to
is that the atomic planes are
mirror-like
are mirror-like i mean this is sort of
an obvious assumption since i've been
assuming they've been mirrors
but you know it's it's not so
if you start thinking about atom
position
then you might go back to that you know
that selection rule picture
and say oh wait a second why you know
does it always have to hit the atom
there what if this one was over
or something like that no no we assume
it's just one continuous plane
if there are atoms in it if there are
atoms in it
right if there's no atom in it then it's
not a reflective plane
okay but it's continuous in the
assumption of of the bragg condition
okay now um
now we go back to our picture okay so
what we want to do
is again our goal our goal should we
choose
should we choose our goal is to go from
this spectrum
knowing this information right it's a
copper target
and and we and being able to read off
the peaks our goal
is to determine the crystal structure
and the lattice constant
that's our goal and and let me
let me just write this again because
it's extremely
important so i'm gonna i'm gonna maybe
i'll keep that one
i'm gonna ignore i'm gonna erase this
and put it right in the middle
because this is this is what
drives xrd this is what drives xrd
okay which is that our goal
is
figure out
what makes
this
constant always constant
now you say what is this constant always
okay this is the expression which i'm
going to write again just for
so so the what i have if it's a copper
source
is 1.54 angstroms divided by 2a
squared that's a constant goes in tight
that equals sine squared
of the theta for some plane divided by
h squared plus k squared
plus l squared so i'm just kind of
repeating what i've said and what i've
written elsewhere but that is really it
that is what we do in x-ray diffraction
what makes this well by this
what i mean is this term on the right
how do i make sure that this never
changes its value
because the thing on the left never
changes its value
right and just making sure that you've
got that concept
that is this oh yeah
okay and and it turns out
i got i got a set i got a recipe for you
to follow to do this and it's on the
previous slide and so so we'll start
thinking about it
now and we've got five more minutes and
then on friday we will
we will finish this and then talk about
what to do with those continuous x-rays
so what do i do well the the way you do
this is systematically
because in tight the way you do this is
systematically
and the first thing you do is you read
off the two theta values
okay that generate a set of sine squared
values so
the x-ray spectrum measures 2 theta but
we know from here that i need sine
squared
okay so i'm going to write down the sine
squared values
okay so that's a first step so
okay good right so for the first one
i've got uh okay so i've got the first
peak
so i would start to log my data right
the first peak
and the 2 theta is 38.43
and the sine squared theta okay
is and i'm just going to do that math
0.1083
okay okay good and the next one
the next peak is 44.67
and the sine squared of that is 0.14
four four and so on so you read off all
the peaks and you make that
those columns okay so i've gone through
one now the second one
normalize the sine squared theta values
by the smallest value
right okay you say why am i doing that
trust me
this will achieve our goal this will get
us there
this is a nice simple recipe to achieve
our goal so the next column
would simply be sine squared
theta divided by sine
squared theta min
okay well i ran out of room there but
that's going to be obviously
one and this would be one point
three three three and so on
so that's the next one so i'm just i'm
just setting the
the top row to one
okay i'm setting the top row of 1. so
that's
okay good now i'm going to clear
fractions so i've normalized and now i'm
going to clear fractions
and if i do that if i clear fractions
well you know you say i what is does
clearing fractions mean
it means just what it implies i don't
want fractions anymore so i'm going to
multiply it means i just need to
multiply
the whole set of numbers by by something
that gets rid of the fractions and it
turns out
that in this case it is three so
three times
sine squared theta over sine squared
theta min
and that is going to be three and that
is going to be four
and so on okay so this is this is the
product now
we're almost there we're almost there
and we're not going to finish today but
we're getting real close
that's good it leaves us with a sense of
anticipation
and excitement right so
okay i got clear fractions what values
of
hkl if i have this h squared plus k
squared plus l squared
would give me the sequence of clear
fractions what values of h
now remember you say why am i doing this
again go back to this this is why
i have a simple recipe for you to
accomplish this goal
that's where we're going with this right
okay so so
i'm now gonna see with those clear
fractions now it's very easy
to see what hkls would give me h squared
plus k plus
h squared plus k squared plus l squared
equals that clear fraction value
right so for example you know
here well if this is h squared plus k
squared plus l squared maybe this is one
one one
right and this might be two zero zero
for example okay
so we're almost there we're so close um
what we're gonna do is i'm gonna start
on friday i'll put this up on the board
and we'll finish filling it out and
going from this matrix
to the crystal structure and the lattice
constant okay
have a great halloween
you